ma quanti trophies questo esistono
quanti perché ne esce uno di 3 secondi
perché io vado al cesso thorne ce ne
sono altri due ditro fisco e così hanno
fatto trophies quest per le serie tv è
per me i videogiochi di nuova
generazione possono accompagnare solo io
lo faccio lo faccio e so che ci saranno
un miliardo di riferimenti alle serie tv
la premessa è questa se non conosco una
di queste serie tv non cagate ma un
cazzo ok perché non è che posso vederle
tutte so tipo in questo game of thrones
vai al gioco è papà in partenza sempre
geniale travis questi mission ragazzi ci
siamo altro che netflix bel gioco vai se
voi riconosce allora qualcuno mi faccia
il favore mi scriva sotto nei commenti
il livello 1 ranger tings livello 2 che
non essere già in sta roba prove al
dottor house e mi deve fare la diagnosi
al polpaccio
va bene a si doveva trattare la testa
per farsi venire un'idea e fai qualcosa
che ne so io oggi per grattare ancora di
più perfetto
adesso devo andarmene questo è il prof
questo livello completato bene il primo
andato sherlock holmes credo potrei dire
una cagata allora queste watson a quanto
riesco a trattenere il respiro
ma cos'è ma perché no perché devo fare
qualcosa nel mentre che respiro cosa
devo fare
sicuramente devo fare quel confronto
quanti livelli a sto gioco 10 grazie a
dio sono pochi grazie a dio prossimo
daryl ho riconosciuto prima ma no non è
del kick ass
ma questa non è che è roldi non è che
qualcuno mi spiega cos'è star non va beh
ho un mitra bello bellissimo va bene ok
proprio devo fare no vabbè fermi esigo
la spiegazione
se qualcuno ce la vorrei averla grazie
così è
ma cos'è stasera sta roba non lo so
spiega temi che cos'è raschi voglio
saperlo
oddio beavis and butthead mi chiamava
don mario amato su quattro non nominate
2 per adesso è già qualcosa va bene è
beavis and butthead non so per quale
motivo però li clicco e ridono ok la
rosa granata dall'araldo adesso prende
meglio dati imperativo continua dietro
la la la tu sei ragazzi a cosa sa cosa
sto giocando spiega perché ho aperto sto
gioco che questi rigon a comando
[Applauso]
presto rende orgoglioso me stesso di
fare lo youtube grazie progresso
tecnologico che mi dà sempre una mano
nel scoprire nuove bellissime avventure
videoludiche
e se sta roba cowes resto non lo conosco
c'è un rombo verde che trasforma in
carta igienica le persone orfei e in
store anni giusto fare così perché non
conosco mezza serie tv perché sono tutto
disinformato sulle serie tv a posso
usare lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo lo
sapevo che avrei dovuto utilizzare stock
o lo sapevo ma perfetto prossimo livello
ragazzi sempre più fiero di questo
videogioco non conosco neanche ma
neanche mezza serie tv ma da una volta
faccio schifo
cos'era sta roba cosa hicks file che
credo sia i file non lo so la tipa una
gnocca però non capisco
sì credo sia i files quasi sicuramente
va bene curiosi tarlo fare qualcosa che
non vedo come al solito perché tante
sempre così sempre però sono un genio e
continua a cliccare la cosa che non devo
cliccare perfette le marche
oddio spoiler spero lo sia uno spoiler
però non l'aver sarebbe troppo figo non
è uno spoiler ragazzi speriamo non ha
tratto di quello fallito un lodo no non
ho vinto tanto più cazzo guardi
doppio spoiler ancora peggio va bene
adesso siamo tutti amici quindi sticazzi
ok ok figo molto figo
pensate che con tutti quanti quest'ora
livello fatto meglio
ditemi voi prossimo livello ragazzo o la
famiglia addams questa la conosco solo
questa per adesso solo questa una delle
pochissime che correva per che guardavo
il cartone da piccolo più che altro zio
fester ma perché è pure ritmo ma no per
chiari sono tutti tranne lui facesse
reti due vie la finiana se non sapremo
lui non ride lui lui è triste a
prescindere tratto ragazzi normali che
la nonna non ha le braccia che erano le
braccia sono cagato addosso
ma l'assenza
ma poi sono cagato addosso per niente
prossimo livello ragazzi ne mancano due
dio ce ne scampi better control e con
questo possiamo chiudere e sono due di
fila che so è better consola freccia
indica la porta apriamo la porta
cazzo è quello stesso tanto non l'ho mai
visto ben percorso prova le chicche
ma perché ma perché smat smat e schifo
ma perché e ride
ok è in rendo il match tra tutti forse
il livello anche più sensato fighter 9
dexter dexter che sa quanto sono
skillato non essere tv va bene
che faccio dall'altro col cucchiaio col
cucchiaio tutto questo va bene o ragano
spoiler nei commenti del selettivo e non
fatti bastardi che a me non me ne frega
niente però per gli altri non fatti
bastardi ecco questo questo di sicuro
erano spoiler poi non lo so livello
conteggiato ragazzi siamo all'ultimo e
sono troppo curioso ma scusami ma non
c'è game of thrones l'hanno messo solo
nella copertina del gioco per farsi
belli e lo faccio anch'io nel video di
youtube allora tutti che tutti che click
day tano comunque in conclusione non so
che cosa sia sta roba però vabbè cazzo
ride ma perché lei è stato un livello
bellissimo va bene gioco completato 1384
click che è decisamente più del solito
ci ho messo molto di più del solito
vabbè erano questi che non ho capito
perché non c'è
non c'era game of thrones però nella
copertina del gioco c'era vigata sta
roba ragazzi fatemi sapere nei commenti
se avete beccato tutte e dieci le serie
tv io non ho da herat a lamela metà ma è
comunque la beccate 45 se beccate voi
tutto il resto siete dei fenomeni
ragazzi miei spero che questo tra fisco
e sia stato molto di vostro gradimento
rispetto agli ace che poi tra l'altro in
italiano per la cazzo cambia italiano e
dall'italiano all'inglese cosa alla
scritta iniziale up grazie turco la
prossima volta lo gioco magari ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto come al solito
subito misure sul momento mi piace anche
valida come didatta notizia se non si sa
quali si discrete riciclavano prossimo
video o la prossima serie tv non spoiler
da ragazzi
[Musica]